we're done goes into a real game show
exactly uh Bachelorette number one hi
guys hi
that was perfect thank you so much
smashed it
I'm here with Joseph Oh what's up it's
so exciting he's here to record an
episode of not too deep but while he's
here I thought that we would play a
really fun and kind of embarrassing not
for us for these people games yeah we're
gonna play who's first tweet is that
where director producer of nacho deep
Jack Ferry off camera is gonna read a
first tweet and we have a series of
names random names yeah we have
youtubers like alfie deyes musicians and
famous personalities like Yoko Ono we
have family members like Tim Helbig so
there's a there's a variety here
do you feel confident no I mean my first
tweet there's like nothing like I tweet
now son this is gonna be the worst thing
ever
I'm pretty sure my first tweet was like
is this thing on or something so lame I
think that was mine too something along
the lines of like trying look I already
know this medium so well I can make fun
of it for the first time out and and
yeah people's first tweets I think we're
gonna find are pretty embarrassing so
let's do it okay we're gonna play first
to seven is the winner so you're gonna
read out the tweet okay oh yeah Jack's
gonna read out the tweet I'm like
telling you how to do it I'm like okay
he's gonna tell us if we got it wrong if
we get it wrong then we have to choose
again until one of us gets it correct
okay if if you guys both are right it's
the first person that chose yeah so it's
still a bit of a speed thing all right
yeah all right here we go are we ready
yes all right graduating in 13 days
WTF 13 days WTF yes really
what Cory's like yeah the only person
out of all of these people who ever went
to call it oh god damn it fine then all
Twitter what
fine then I'll Twitter
no no dah
um yeah who's witty enough hungry hungry
its young green good damn it hey this
fashion yeah you are it's two to zero my
camera's broken sad face and where's
Bergen who has a camera Phil uh Alfie
deyes yes Josh got one sorry to brain
fart there I will shout for the all-caps
okay oh there you go
I'm very happy because it's another snow
day
Kanye West oh no no it wasn't Kanye West
I'm very happy because it was snow day
Mitchell Davis he lives in my snowy
surely no no it's not close Lu there
goes L happy okay please please you're
gonna know and talked about surveys
Drake's from Canada no no Jack Howard
yeah yeah this is tough I really was
hoping that it would be Drake whatever
in awesome ah okay it's how are you
three I want I thought I was too legit
to quit
damn son it's on Yoko militant a little
accident
um no 100 what please please please
please
ah no no what Oh glozell no no what is
their fake ones
no no um I can't even remember who I've
done who I have a know enough maimry
mom maybe that's so embarrassing
that's your first tweet jam son then
your first tweet
oh you're catching up so this is very
intense I'm sweating alright this is
almost physical activity I've done in
alone all right
all lowercase just for context oh it's
got to be filled hello out there
dot dot dot this is my first Twitter
smiley face yeah I was gonna do that too
no no oh no no Mitchell Davis yeah yes
yes making a comeback tide for y'all
what are these muscles here your pecs my
yes not grabbing them I just realized
I'm completely just like grabbing my own
boobs in yellow that's great thank you
for a thumbnail otherwise the wait is
over November 23rd
Oh 9 no no Rihanna ah what did she do on
that day that was that significand
Twitter the way oh that's the day she
joined I guess I mean that's her first
tweet oh I was gonna say she's already
promoting her album yeah you know that's
like some record label person
haha four three here we go gay mom
apologizing to a very needy cat for
being gone so long cats um no no yes
hey who is it how does she have cats I
thought it was like a thing for her this
is a tight race sports all right um
there's also some all caps so when I
shout alright here we go
just got into Berlin dot feelin better
thank you have my Vic's inhaler by my
bedside and PS our twitter gah such a
follower no no oh yes yeah yeah I'm back
on top okay good it's not done yet for -
Evan I don't even remember signing up
for this argh
no no what yes amazingphil oh yeah okay
this is so intense now yeah this is who
knew that I all of my future rests on
Yoko Ono's first tweet there we go guys
this is all all caps okay new song and
visual from my new album being projected
to that across the globe on 66 buildings
location
at Lake yes Kanye Kanye West calm oh my
god
I think Kanye OS has a keyboard that's
just one capsize that's it there's no
punctuation and it's all lowercase just
so you can visualize it
dancing y-yeah Christi I just think
everything that she does is so cool and
adorable I'm just imagining it like yeah
that's a no just so tweeting about it
yeah tweet like dancing but taking the
time to tweet this is a thing well Troy
thank you for playing this game thank
you so much
come on now yeah this is how I love my
guests to ruin my day yeah I welcome
them with open losing arms we haven't
even done the podcast yet yeah so that's
gonna be a really great podcast guys
make sure you go over to iTunes and
SoundCloud to listen to the full thing
my Energy's gonna be really really great
it's just gonna be silent the whole time
in yo test what she dress
okay guys at Troy has an e peak a wild
that yay that's out now they can go get
it on iTunes Spotify everything now now
do it your ears will thank you later and
if they do how do your ears talk
that's so cute that's a no guys alright
thank you
hey that's a Yoko Ono tweet yeah see you
next time guys thank you so much bye and
then do you want to show you the work
yes me please see the walk okay strange
noises